start of day to walk in the park at
parks might actually open yet Oh
thousand electric fence
and that's an idea spectacle back I
think it's cool Cueto so gates the first
digit for thee to use now
and she gorgeous
I feel obliged to point out by the way
the reason I just bumped into an
electric fence is it turns out I was
where people want to post feed those
visitors I suppose I'm tends not really
a visitor on the what other things might
be closer to it they're really
three-dimensional to go like 30 odd feet
off the ground pretty high on the ground
and these two bears just don't play
fighting like in front of it I've never
seen anything like it and they all
chilled out just to touch me to get a
proper ship on and then they've just
gone back it's like because the thing of
any closure is that animals always have
the option to go inside if they don't
want to be viewed they don't have to be
viewed and then contributes to on the
major reasons why the animals here on
the stresses that I have because on the
major causes of stress is the idea that
you can't escape you can't get away
so they decided they'd had a private
sanctuary but hell of a start of the day
okay so through a few setbacks today
things I've done quite plan because one
of the keepers isn't actually in there
still away so I'm not doing Tamra's
today I hope you'll be doing bat oh my
god my hay fever starts to make the most
of the time I am here in one of the
Averys is tropical Avery with birds just
flying free and I'm gonna get some shots
because effective have any been taking
shots of mammals so far so I'm trying to
take my time here because I know this is
dad's favorite enclosure my dad is a
massive he loves Birds I seem to quit my
parents do he loves fish so when we come
in here here deal it's amazing because
the purses don't care the most is just
so much around here it was really nice
to be around some really lovely species
me I'm gonna get them I'm not gonna try
and save any species I'm gonna get
hummingbirds pretty much the most
frustrating thing ever
it's so quickly but the time you move
your camera and got focus there God give
me good rivers every day I can hear them
everywhere okay so good people just came
out to me to assume that I work here and
asked me a whole bunch of questions
about the red-billed shop introductory
introduction in Jersey I think you
thought I did wear this because I wanted
to look a little more official when I
went into the cages didn't think that
would happen like I had to just make up
but I was new here and I worked in the
media side of things and everyone's
telling me that I should really watch
the country for episode that just came
out okay so I'm behind the scenes here
this is the earth pathology department
after all these behind me
you could not try to find me neither I
just didn't interview in here with the
head of herpetology Matt he was just
very casually holy the entire interview
in fact I was taking lots of shots very
from one of these cages this one
slightly teller was chilling I was I was
there looking it looking pretty surely a
lot dangerous
pretty pretty sure this is a fascinating
species really I mean I can't do it I'm
gonna be able to talk as anywhere near
as well as maps so make sure you check
out the Doral video when that comes out
and he'll feature in some videos on my
channel as well really lovely guy very
passionate about this job had a head of
the herpetology knows this stuff real
privilege to do this real real privilege
also it turns out that they use their
time in queue beta because it's the most
thermally regulated room in the building
so he's literally just in there there is
a toilet and next to a bunch of
accidents in the world where a snake
so I'm just getting ready to go in with
the tamarins behind me we're going in
with these these of hi Tamron
who we just found out well I just found
out that you can't take a bagging
because they are terrified if anything
that they can be bundled into
sorry I'm not like a kid can you hear
that
yes I know it's coming
come on
so they're probably going to be up wind
from the camera that'll make sense so if
you want if you want to film them
feeding on that branch and it would be
additionally and then then they might
you might be a defense that's gonna be
the second camera
see they go so soon as it goes the other
way around you'll get a lot more yeah
that's right yeah so just want the ends
of these disturbed in life okay so I'm
actually in here with the tamarins at
the moment we just did loads and loads
of filming and then if you can see that
past my shoulder those are pipe tamarins
how endangered are they in the wild what
kind of money
these are critical how many numbers so
1500 so there's and not unsubstantial
fraction of them that I'm in here with
right now
right right there they also like using
me as a climbing frame it turns out
that was one of the most incredible
experiences of my life
I wish you haven't stopped grinning
since I came in here Wow okay so now
room with box like
these are Rodriguez and Livingston three
bats I was filming them all yesterday I
have been told not to let them touch me
because they have rabies and I have had
rabies shots water so they might have
rabies
and so they touch me I might have
hospital
so I just finished filming in with the
bats kind of amazing I got peed on I
think I'm gonna get a bit pull on me as
well but you know the opportunity to do
that you get peed on by one the world's
rarest bats I think that's worth it
although admittedly being told oh by the
way these almost completely silent and
highly mobile creatures might possibly
have rabies so fall on the bike to you
then you're gonna have to get a hospital
ASAP not one of the most reassuring
things I've been told were entered into
a cage so I actually haven't planned on
doing this but behind me I think if you
can see it on the
and its future Simon again what I was
going to say it was that that was the
last echo parakeet in captivity because
it was a massive conservation success
and there's a few species like that
actually on the site where they've been
really successful in their conservation
reintroduction programs and so they
don't need to keep them in captivity
anymore which is exactly why that double
exists in the first place
so I'm not back in hospital and evening
currently trying to process everything
that happened to me today
also nursing at I like know this one I
can we get in can we can i cool I
basically jab myself in the eye with a
bit of vegetation and the tamarind
enclosure so the most dangerous thing in
that whole enclosure was was a leaf
rather than the actual tamarins who I
never actually felt threatened by you
know like they were climbing on me a
little bit but that was fine it believes
what I was worried but then hey view my
hay fever so bad here because I don't
know maybe there's different kind of
polymer I'm not used to until my eyes
are just like but yeah I've been going
through some of the footage just quickly
actually the ones stuff taking on this
camera it has so happy some of the stuff
that's come out been so so good today is
just been crazy